LG has a new watch phone. It's not the first watch phone,...
...but it's the first touchscreen watch phone from the company.
So Martin, tell us how it works.
Check it out! You've got your analog screen,...
...what you can do is get yourself a digital screen as well.
Wow!
This is cool. Now, that's just the watch feature of it.
Now, let's get to the cooler stuff. Right here in the corner, you've got a camera.
All right, camera guys.
Now, when you wanna make a phone call, of course, you just go to the phone screen...
...and there it is. This is capacitive touch. If you wanna know what that is,...
...that means you need to use the tip of your finger.
Not your fingernail, but the tip of your finger to make a phone call.
The send key is right here, the end key is right there, but,...
...you could also use the bluetooth headset to make the call.
This has voice activated dialing, so if you press the number right here,...
...it'll tell you to say a command right there.
Please say a command, and you say the command, and you make the phone call.
And this is an MP3 player as well. MP3 player is not the last and greatest thing.
What it is, it has tempered glass on it, so it's scratch resistant.
It'll be hard to scratch this. You're worried about getting caught in the rain,...
...don't be. This is also water resistant as well.
Wow! So, this is the magic phone. When is it coming out?
It's coming out later this year, out in Europe.
And how much will it cost?
We're not sure yet.